hi there steve here today i want to talk
a little bit about chinese
because because we're introducing
traditional characters to link so people
who are interested in learning
traditional characters
uh they can get on and literally whoops
it's a bit windy out here
literally anything
that uh is in our uh library in
simplified character you can convert it
to traditional and upload it in the
traditional slot
we're also going to be
starting cantonese
but
so i those of you are interested the
that's good news
i did mention in a previous video that
we can now import
youtube videos directly
into link to study using our chrome
extension or browser extensions
and so that a lot of material in can in
chinese which has captions is available
to study as lessons at link now
chinese
first thing about chinese is that it's
not as difficult as people say
it has certain difficulties i would say
difficulty number one is the characters
it's a lot of work
but it's a matter of staying with it and
doing it every day finding a system that
works for you
i think uh characters chinese characters
is one area where deliberate
vocabulary study
is helpful especially i found for the
first 1000 characters after that you
come across them in reading you're more
familiar with the components
uh it's a little bit easier to pick them
up on the fly but characters and as you
know i believe in input-based learning
input-based learning means reading
chinese is a language where it's really
helpful to read and to read a lot and to
work on your characters from day one and
spend a lot of time reading so that's
difficulty number one difficulty number
two of course is the tones
but here again
remember that everything that seems so
strange at first in any language
gradually
there's a snowball effect it becomes
more and more familiar and easier to
learn
i wouldn't put a lot of effort in trying
to nail the pronunciation at the
beginning i would put a lot of effort
into listening getting used to hearing
the tones
as a little bit of wind here
uh
so that so the second difficulty then is
the tones and it's something that you
will gradually get better at and don't
worry about it
it doesn't inhibit or shouldn't inhibit
your ability to enjoy the language
through
reading and listening the third thing is
vocabulary where there basically are no
common vocabulary items with other
languages except for other some other
you know asian languages
so
uh if we go through the parts of speech
the good news in chinese is that the
grammar is quite simple nouns there's no
plural
well there's a few plurals but
essentially no plural it's uh you know
they do have these
counters even shoes
one car there's a
frame of a car or a stick of a book for
whatever reason
and there's no there's no plural there's
no feminine there's no gender there's no
changing of endings nothing so it's it's
that easy you just have to learn
the nouns what they mean
uh verbs again no change
that's yesterday tomorrow
you they add a little at the end to
indicate the past tense but there's a
very little
change in the verbs
um adjectives
again basically quite simple
uh you know the car is very big true car
handa very big car very big
uh
very often
adverbs and adjectives can be used
interchangeably you know cho how quiet
the car is very fast
well paul the hong kong i run fast same
kai so there's a lot of situations like
that where
i think the genius of chinese is that
they have simplified a lot of stuff
and i don't think it's a sign of the
language being less developed i think
it's it's very helpful in fact
uh to have simplified these things uh
you ask questions they just put a ma at
the end
you go nichima are you going
so the ma is like a question mark which
appears in speech pretty straightforward
you can also ask questions like are you
going
you go not go
so there's a lot of very basic putting
words together in a very practical way
to produce meaning
which is kind of refreshing at times
compared to some of the more complicated
structure grammatically
can not confusing but difficult
languages
um what else is there basically that's
it
you have to tackle the characters
uh up front start early and keep going
at it every single day
uh oh the other thing about chinese
don't get caught up in any grammatical
explanations terms or whatever it's all
a matter of patterns
might be 50 or 100 different patterns
you know
uh
if you do something then i will
[Music]
get a yeah book that focuses on patterns
that's how you should learn the language
and i'm going to get in out of the wind
here i hope that was helpful
bye for now
[Music]
you